for the latest now in racialized
brainwashing we turn to arizona where
the arizona department of education has
developed an
equity toolkit which contains lots of
surprising information but nothing more
surprising than this according to
the arizona department of ed babies are
racist
journalist chris ruffo has the material
which begins with a chart
detailing uh the course of a young
child's life from birth to about six
years old
and at the top it tells us uh that quote
they're not too young to talk about race
continuing it says young children notice
and think about race
adults often worry that talking about
race will encourage racial bias in
children but the opposite is true
silence about race reinforces racism by
letting children draw their own
conclusions based on what they see
now wait let's stop right there for a
moment because uh so you're saying we're
not supposed to let children draw their
own conclusions
really but aren't these the same people
who tell us that we have to respect the
child's self-determined gender
identity at the age of three so we
should let a three-year-old
a three-year-old boy we should let him
draw his own conclusions about whether
or not he's actually a boy
but he can't draw his own conclusions
about race
okay got it all right back to the fact
sheet it says well not a fact cheat but
it is a sheet anyway
and it goes on it says teachers and
families can play a powerful role in
helping children of all ages develop
positive attitudes about race and
diversity
and skills to promote a more just future
but only if we talk about it first
and from there we follow the child over
the course of his young racist life
first we're told quote at birth babies
look equally at faces of all races at
three months babies look more at faces
that match the race of their caregivers
my god those shameless bigots see i
always suspected this you know
when my youngest was a newborn and she
would cry for mommy
and i would always say to her you only
want mommy because she's white i know
you're game
i'm on to you see it's very important to
call out the nazi babies
when you see them even if it's your own
child and i know it could be a difficult
thing
it can be a difficult thing to look at
your three-month three-month-old and
realize
that she is a nazi but this is something
that you have to do as a parent
anyway then it says children as young as
two years old um
use race to reason about people's
behaviors
then by 30 months most children use race
to choose playmates
side note my primary problem here is
that they said
30 months like i can't stand it when
people identify their kids ages by
months because it forces me to do math
which i don't want to have to do
so when someone says like yes my child
is 87 and a half months old
continuing it says expressions of racial
prejudice often peak at ages four and
five so this is like when it
when someone is the most racist is is is
at four
and then it says by five black and
latinx children
in research settings show no preference
towards their own groups compared to
white
white children at this age remain
strongly biased in favor of whiteness
well yeah that i just flat out don't
believe um
it's certainly exactly the result that
the researchers hoped to find
and that's why i don't believe it
clearly bogus but we'll keep going
it says by by kindergarten children show
many of the same racial attitudes that
adults in our culture hold
hold they have already learned to
associate some groups with higher status
than others
and finally explicit conversations with
five to seven-year-olds about
interracial friendships
can dramatically improve their racial
attitudes in as little as a single week
okay let's break this down there are
three problems here well there's a lot
more than three but we only have a few
minutes for this segment so let's focus
on three first
contrary to what has become popular
belief at least popular belief among
people who work for the school system
it is not actually the school system's
job to combat racism or to make children
more
racially and morally enlightened or
anything like that
its job is to educate children in the
subjects that parents
send their children to school for math
history science etcetera abcs and one
two threes that's basically it
now you might argue that it's not really
possible in practice to separate
factual and moral education you might
say that all education will inherently
have the goal
of making children into better people
that is better according to the
standards and values of the educator
so i'm sympathetic to that view in fact
i agree with it
that's just another reason to get your
kids the hell out of the public school
system as i'm always urging
everybody moral formation is
always a part of education uh we may say
that in the case of the public school
system
it shouldn't be that's not the system's
job
it's not what you send your children
there for that's all true but the two
will not be separated and never have
been separated
so if you don't want your child to be
morally formed or malformed by the
system
you have to extract your child from that
system
second point on the issue of racist
babies
is it true that children show a
preference for their own race
yeah probably to some extent sure
it's probably true true that even very
young children do
three months old they're told we're told
now
there really isn't any way to know what
a three-month-old is thinking
but we have no idea about the inner life
of a three-month-old
we were all three months old at one time
some of us act like we still are
but none of us can remember what that's
like so it's a strange thing that
something we all experienced is so
mysterious to us but that's
that's what it means to be human that's
part of the human condition
yet to the extent that we can develop
some ideas about
how babies think and what they think
it's probably true that they have quote
racial preferences
why well because they're going to
gravitate towards people
who look like their own families
it's that simple a baby when she first
starts saying mama and dada
she's likely to say it to every woman
who looks vaguely like her mama and
every man who looks vaguely like her
dada
she's drawing connections and
correlations she's noticing similarities
noticing patterns
she doesn't understand them she doesn't
assign moral
value to anything but she notices them
this is normal this is fine this is
healthy there's no problem here it's not
racism
i can't believe i have to explain this
but it's not racism
yeah i i shouldn't need to explain that
your three-month-old is
has a preference for mommy and women who
look like mommy
and that it's not because she's racist
like i shouldn't have to explain that
but apparently i do
see racism is the belief that certain
races are inferior
racism is for example how blm activists
treat white people that's racism
if you treat another race with animosity
hatred vengeance that's racism
little kids don't have any of that
they just might feel most comfortable
feel safest around people who look
the most like mama and dada
not only is that not racist but it's
actually good it's good that a child has
a special connection with his
tribe and his tribe for him is his
family
this is biologically ingrained it's
it's supposed to be that way it should
be that way
when a child gets scared or nervous
around a stranger she runs and hugs
daddy's leg hides behind him
she wants to be closer to the person she
knows
she feels safe around there's no reason
to
actively deprogram this instinct
children will kind of grow out of it
naturally and that's and that's fine too
but of course the left can never let a
child just grow
naturally anymore they cannot let that
happen
and that brings us to the third point
we're told to talk
with our children about race and if we
don't talk about race
then they'll be racist that's the claim
but i think the opposite is the case
in fact i prefer the advice given by
morgan freeman years ago i don't know if
you
maybe you've heard this is a famous clip
but if you haven't um and i don't know
if he would still say this now
in our uber woke era but 15 or 20 years
ago
when asked about this subject here's
what he said slack
history month you find ridiculous
why you're going to relegate my history
to a month
oh come on what do you do with yours
what which month is white history month
come on tell me well
i'm jewish okay which month is jewish
history month
uh there isn't one oh oh
why not yeah do you want one no no no
i i don't either i don't want a black
history month
black history is american history how
are we going to get rid of racism
unstoppable talking about it
i'm gonna stop calling you a white man
yeah i'm gonna ask you to stop calling
me
a black man i know you as mike wallace
you know me as morgan freeman
okay stop talking about it there's more
wisdom in that 55 second clip of a
hollywood actor than all of the critical
race theory toolkits and seminars that
have ever been devised
i can say anecdotally this was my
experience as a child
i noticed when someone was a different
race if somebody looked different
i noticed that obviously i wondered
about it i may have i may have asked
questions like why do they look
different the kinds of questions
that all kids have the questions that my
kids have had
totally normal but it never occurred to
me as a child to make a big
thing out of it i didn't draw any
sweeping conclusions based on the fact
that somebody looked different
as a kid you play with whoever else
happens to be on the playground what is
their race matter
that's the great thing about kids i mean
mine will make a new best friend with
anyone some random child they meet in
the food court at the zoo
whoever as children learn to branch out
a little bit and talk to and befriend
people outside of their family units
they embark on that quest
without baggage they don't have all this
baggage they just go out there and kids
are kids and
and uh and and all of that the baggage
is added later
by garbage like this by critical race
theorists and other assorted race
hustlers
see kids don't naturally see race as a
big deal they see race of course
everybody does
they don't see it as a big deal you have
to make it a big deal
that's why the left has to work so hard
to convince them to see it as a big deal
that's why they walk up and they say oh
i see you too a black and a white child
are getting along well
let me tell you about the legacy of
slavery and the evils of systemic racism
they walk away satisfied that they have
just created racial animosity and
suspicion where it hadn't previously
existed
they say the goal is to defeat racism
but it's exactly the opposite they are
brainwashing kids
into racism they are introducing it
inculcating it
planting the seeds and watching it grow
and we all have to read what they have
sowed
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content